today we're going to talk about one of
the questions that we get sent in a lot
at numberphile and the question is well
Brady what's the question the question
is why does zero factorial equal one
right why does zero factorial equal one
so they start off with a quick recap of
what a factorial is for a whole number
let's pick a number n n factorial which
is written like that and with an
exclamation mark this is equal to you
multiply all the whole numbers less than
and equal to n its n multiplied by n
minus 1 multiplied by n minus 2
multiplied by and you keep going down
and you'll go down to 3 times 2 times 1
a quick example let's do 5 factorial 5
times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1 and you
do that it's 120 ok the question we've
been asked is what is 0 factorial so the
way you can answer is one of the ways
you can answer it is to complete the
pattern let's complete the pattern this
pattern in particular for factorial is
equal to 5 factorial divided by 5 if you
can see that if I take 5 factorial here
and divide by 5 that means I can knock
off that 5 you end up with 4 factorial
so 5 factorial divided by 5 or 120
divided by 5 that's 24 that's 4
factorial 3 factorial it's going to be 4
factorial divided by 4 that's 24 divided
by 4 by 6 that's the answer to 3
factorial 2 factorial 3 factorial
divided by 3 6 which you've just worked
out divided by 3 equals 2 1 factorial do
it again is 2 factorial divided by 2 2
factorial is 2 divided by 2 we've got to
develop yeah that's equal to 1 and now
this is where it's getting exciting do
you feel the anticipation so 0 factor
we're going to complete the pattern 0
factorial is 1 factorial divided by 1 1
factorial is 1
it's 1/1 and that is equal to 1 so 0
factorial is equal to 1 you complete the
pattern who says the pattern has to be
complete where's that rule come from I
guess you doesn't necessarily have to be
yeah a pattern that completes it is a
pattern that completes though let me try
another way to explain it let me
continue the pattern first does that
make sure we try negative 1 factorial
would be next in that sequence let's see
what happens I'm not sure what's gonna
happen this tri minus 1 factorial so
what should I get
nope factorial divided by not 1 divided
by not you've broken maths Brady stop
that another way to explain what 0
factorial might be n factorial is the
number of ways you can arrange n objects
and let me just try to show you what I
mean let's get some objects I'll get the
wallet out I'll get some coins out see
who says mathematicians don't make a lot
of money there's literally 50 P here
let's pick a silver one and 5p back
three objects here and how many ways are
there to arrange three objects there's
six ways to do it it's three factorial
let's just check them that's one that's
two or we could have this one here
that's three that's four or we could
have I think it was that one we didn't
have at the front so that'd be five and
six if we take one away we have now two
objects how many ways are there to
arrange two objects that's one that's to
take one away
how many ways other to arrange one
object though it is there's one way to
do it one way to arrange one object now
we're going to take the last coin away
this is where it gets a little
philosophical we have zero objects how
many ways are there to arrange zero
objects there's one way to do it there
is do I see me do it again but is
it slightly philosophical but we say
there are there is one way to arrange
zero objects so again the pattern holds
zero factorial equals one as just to
continue the idea just a little bit
further if we're talking about
factorials let's just trying to graph
them sooo they say just have one two
three four one factorial is 1 so if we
call it 1 2 factorial is 2 so somewhere
about here 3 factorial is 6 I know
somewhere like this 4 factorial is 24 so
that's going to be actually quite high
up here and in fact Ollie's going hey if
we join these together I've also said
that 0 factorial is 1 so I reckon this
is the graph so in theory we should be
able to get values for in between like
say the number one and a half one and a
half factorial what is 1 and 1/2
factorial so mathematicians have done
that they've generalized the idea and
there is the idea of one-and-a-half
factorial we call it gamma that's a
Greek letter gamma we call it gamma of
and the way we write it actually now
this is getting a bit more sophisticated
we say gamma of n is equal to the
integral between 0 and infinity of let's
pick something T to the power n minus 1
multiplied by e to the power minus n DN
that's some people won't be familiar
with that some of you will be familiar
with that some of you won't be so much
more complicated mathematical idea but
this would agree with the factorials it
but it gives you in between values as
well it plots this line there is
something I do need to say it's not is
slightly unexpected but if we take a
value for a whole number gamma of N and
n is whole this actually gives you n
minus 1 factorial so be careful of that
that might catch you out
a bit of a pain that so what's the point
of having a function that will give you
factorials in between whole numbers when
you can't arrange one and a half objects
so it's a generalization and it turns up
quite to be quite useful in many things
particularly I'm thinking of probability
you can use them in a formulas that you
find in probability where you can when
you're thinking about continuous time
instead of just arranging objects and
discrete probability just now starting
about the thing about continuous events
time is the best example then you start
to generalize the ideas and therefore
you need a generalized factorial 9 6